in northern bangladesh just below the
himalayas there's a school unlike any
you've probably seen
rather than brick and mortar buildings
these classrooms float
[Music]
in most of bangladesh the roads are poor
and the environment is powerful
every year over a fifth of the country
floods isolating people in small
villages and cutting kids off from
school
so a man named mohammed rezwan had an
idea
my idea was very simple
if the children cannot go to school then
the school should go to them like both
i am an architect and social
entrepreneur and i am the executive
director and founder of shizune version
floating school in bangladesh
our sweating school works both as a
school bus and school house it picks up
students from several pickup points
arrange classes and again drops to
students other places
there are different boats with different
purposes there are classroom boats
library boats boats for computers and
even ones for play
in groups of 30 kids aged 6 to 10 attend
classes covering the main points of
early childhood education
[Music]
the children learn bengali
english math
drawing this school has a solar power to
run computers it has hundreds of books
it is a place for them to spend quality
time i have to say
[Music]
with millions of children out of school
in bangladesh these kids are getting a
chance that many others don't
a chance to learn and hopefully change
their lives our flooding school is the
only educational option for them
without floating school there is not any
other way for them to learn
the education
can lead a better life for these
children there are millions of people
out there who need this kind of
intervention
[Music]
someone has to do the work and in my
case i was the person to do
it but still a long way to go
[Music]
you